und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend im
Nachtzug nach Kiew vielleicht wirkt die
gemeinsame an- und Abreise ja positiv
auf sogenannte Teambuilding die
europäischen Außenminister und
Ministerinnen hatten jedenfalls viele
Stunden Zeit für informelle Begegnungen
und in ein Kriegsgebiet zu reisen ist ja
auch keine ganz alltägliche Erfahrung
ins Auge fällt allerdings wer bei diesem
historischen Treffen nicht dabei waren
Umgangs und Polens Außenminister ließen
sich vertreten die Ungarn haben ist ja
eh nicht so mit Unterstützung für die
Ukraine und die Polen haben gerade
Wahlkampf da ist die Freundschaft zum
bedrohten Nachbarn plötzlich auch nicht
mehr so uneingeschränkt
hinzu kommt noch der gestrige Wahlsieg
des pro russischen Kandidaten in der
Slowakei
berichtet vom Treffen in Kiew
was für ein Bild was für ein Ort Europas
Außenminister sind nach Kiew gekommen
mitten im Krieg in dem ukrainische
Soldaten sterben auch weil sie Europas
Freiheit verteidigen so sieht das die
Ukraine
durch die Arbeit auf allen Ebenen
sichern wir die Einheit Europas unserer
gemeinsamen Heimat Europas Einheit ist
ohne die Ukraine unmöglich
Gruppenfoto mit dem Präsidenten zum
allerersten Mal in seiner Geschichte Tag
der eu-außenrat außerhalb der EU die
demonstrative Einigkeit aber täuscht die
Außenminister von Polen und Ungarn
lassen sich vertreten nicht alle
Mitgliedsstaaten wollen weitere
Militärhilfen für die Ukraine deshalb
geht es heute in Kiefer auch darum
auszuloten was gemeinsam überhaupt
möglich ist wir sind in einer Phase
glaube ich angekommen wo wir nicht
zweifeln dürfen an unserem Weg der Weg
ist Putin die Mittel wegnehmen
jedenfalls ist
versuchen dass es wehtut in Russland mit
den Sanktionen und Munition und
natürlich Waffen weiter zu liefern in
der großen europäischen Runde ist viel
von Solidarität die Rede es ist die
deutsche Außenministerin die konkreter
wird und eine Verstärkung der
Luftverteidigung ins Spiel bringt denn
im Land gehen auch an diesem Tag die
russischen Angriffe weiter und deswegen
werde ich hier bei meinem zweiten Besuch
im Herbst diesen Jahres hier in Kiew
dafür dass wir als Europäer aber
eigentlich gemeinsam weltweit jetzt alle
Anstrengungen unternehmen um einen
winterschutzschirm aufzustellen aus
Luftverteidigung aus Schutz von
kritischer Infrastruktur und vor allen
Dingen Generatoren
waffenmunition Geld darauf hofft die
Ukraine und bekommt diese Zusage die EU
werde über 5 Milliarden Euro an
Militärhilfen beraten und sich weiter an
der Schulung ukrainischer Militärs
beteiligen
wir fahren damit Portugal ische Soldaten
auszubilden das Ziel heute ist 40.000 in
den nächsten Monaten und das beinhaltet
auch das Spezialtraining für die Piloten
von Kampfjets
am Nachmittag besucht die deutsche
Außenministerin babinier eine Schlucht
in Kiew in der deutsche Einsatzkräfte
1941 die jüdische Bevölkerung
zusammentrieben in zwei Tagen mehr als
33.000 Menschen erschossen ein Ort der
an die deutsche Verantwortung erinnert
und die bundesaußenministerin ist uns
aus Kiew zugeschaltet guten Tag Frau
bärburg
schönen guten Abend im Moment ist noch
schön in Kiew aber der Winter steht
bevor sie haben einen winterschutzschirm
angeregt gibt es in der irgendetwas
konkretes wird zum Beispiel neue
Flugabwehrsysteme geben oder ähnliches
insbesondere bei der Luftverteidigung
müssen wir noch mehr tun wie sie bereits
gesagt haben man spürt hier schon den
Herbst in der Luft und wir haben im
letzten Winter erlebt dass dieser
brutale russische Angriffskrieg auch die
brutalsten Methoden wählt das heißt im
Winter Elektrizitätswerke anzugreifen
mit dem Ziel dass bei -20° dann hier die
komplette Wasserversorgung einfriert und
um das zu verhindern haben wir im
letzten Jahr Generatoren geliefert und
haben aber auch die Luftverteidigung
verstärkt und ich war vor ein paar
Wochen gerade hier habe mir eines dieser
Umspannwerke angeschaut und dadurch
gesehen was diese Schutzschirm den wir
geliefert haben leisten kann ich hier
für Kiew und das müssen wir jetzt
mobilisieren für das gesamte Land dass
wir durch mehr Luft Verteidigung durch
Generatoren sicherstellen dass in diesem
Winter nicht erneut die Humanität nicht
nur angegriffen wird sondern hier an
unterschiedlichen Orten zerstört wird
haben wir denn noch solche Systeme die
wir liefern können
das ist mein eindringlicher Appell an
alle europäischen Partnern die
internationale Gemeinschaft gemeinsam
jetzt ein winterschutzschirm
aufzustellen das heißt wir haben schon
sehr viel geliefert von diesen
hochmodernen ihres teesystem Patriots
und auch Gepard und wir schauen bei uns
jetzt selber europäische Partner schauen
aber vor allen Dingen der Appell
weltweit all diejenigen die gerade diese
patriotsysteme haben gemeinsam dazu
beizutragen dass die Menschen in diesem
Winter nicht wieder im Dunkeln sitzen
müssen frieren müssen und sich sogar
Sorgen machen müssen ob ihre
Wasserversorgung noch steht was denn
Ukraine auch nach eigener Aussage sie
helfen würde wenn sie die Front weiter
nach hinten schieben könnten dazu
bräuchten sie Waffen marschkörper mit
längerer Reichweite das könnten die
deutschen wenn sie wollten sofort
liefern die Chaos aber da tut sich immer
noch nichts in Berlin richtig
genau das ist eine hochkomplexe Frage
mit der wir auch mit den Amerikanern im
engen Austausch sind der ukrainische
Präsident selenski war ja im Weißen Haus
gerade vor kurzem als die Vereinten
Nationen getagt haben in New York dann
in Washington der Bundeskanzler ist mit
im Gespräch also das sind sehr diffizile
Fragen aber ich habe ja hier auch vor
ein paar Wochen gesagt und es ist klar
wie wichtig dass auch dort eine weitere
Unterstützung kommt wie wichtig dass das
für die Menschen hier vor Ort ist aber
es muss wie gesagt bis ins letzte Teil
geplant werden also die Amerikaner
quatschen ansprechen was nun für die
Ukraine sehr beunruhigend ist und
eigentlich auch ganz Europa die dort
jetzt nun alle in persona der
Außenministerin und Außenminister
versammelt sind beunruhigen muss ist
dass er Rückhalt in Teilen des
us-politischen estallations zurückgeht
jetzt konnte man sich ja
haushaltspolitischen Kongress noch nicht
mal einigen welche Schlussfolgerung
ziehen Sie darauf
dass wir jeden Tag auf der ganzen Welt
in Europa aber auch in den USA und im
Rest der Welt erinnern müssen wir können
uns nicht an diesen Krieg gewöhnen
vielleicht haben Sie den Beitrag gerade
gezeigt wir waren hier mit allen
außenministerinnen und Außenminister an
dieser so berühmten Wand wo all die
Gefallenen mit ihrem Foto hängen Väter
Mütter Eltern zum Teil Kinder Freunde
manche gerade erst erwachsen geworden
das ganze Leben noch vor sich und
deswegen sind wir unter anderem als
Außenminister der EU hier um deutlich zu
machen das ist nicht normal ein
Angriffskrieg ist nicht normal das
19-jährige ihre Zukunft ihr Leben nicht
mehr leben können ist nicht normal weil
sie in unserem Jahrhundert einfach
weggebombt werden und das war auch mein
Appell als ich in den USA war an unsere
amerikanischen Freunde gerade auch an
die Republikaner wir brauchen gemeinsam
diese Unterstützung weil es hier eben
nicht nur um die Verteidigung der
Ukraine um die Rettung der Menschen hier
vor Ort geht sondern um die Verteidigung
unser Friedensordnung in Europa und ich
habe aber viele Republikaner auch so
verstanden dass wenn es dann darauf
ankommt wir wissen alle wie Innenpolitik
ist aber wenn es darauf ankommt dass es
auch von amerikanischer Seite diese
Unterstützung weitergeben wird bröckelt
Unterstützung aber ja auch innerhalb
Europas also dieses Treffen findet statt
einen Tag nach der Wahl in der Slowakei
da konnten eine pro russische Partei an
die Regierung die noch nicht mal mehr
Militärhilfe für die Ukraine leisten
will er Orban freut sich in Ungarn freut
sich über einen neuen Verbündeten auf
dieser pro russischen Seite wie will die
EU damit umgehen
indem wir jeden Tag gemeinsam
um diese Mehrheiten werben deswegen sind
wir gemeinsam hier hier sind fast alle
EU-Außenminister wenn gerade gewählt
wurde in der Slowakei dann kann
derjenige natürlich nicht mit dabei sein
wir müssen auch sehen wie sich da die
Regierungsbildung dann entsprechend
zusammensetzt aber natürlich geht es
darum dass wir die Unterstützung in der
gesamten EU weiter leisten das haben wir
auch mit Ungarn auch wenn es nicht immer
einfach war in den letzten anderthalb
Jahren hingekommen und alle spüren hier
alle die mit mir hier sind ob es nun die
finden ist ob es meine französische
Kollegin ist auf mein tschechischer
Kollege ist oder mein portugiesischer
wir alle spüren hier wenn man mit den
Menschen redet wie wichtig es ist äh
dass diese Unterstützung fort geleistet
wird weil wir sind hier alle mit dem Zug
gekommen mit dem Nachtzug das ist unser
Europa wir sind hier mitten in Europa
und deswegen geht es auch um unsere
Freiheit um unseren Frieden auf unserem
Kontinent sagt die deutsche
Außenministerin Frau Werbung danke für
das Gespräch
danke ebenso
auch wieder rechtzeitig im Zug
zurücksetzt haben wir das Interview am
späten Nachmittag aufgezeichnet
Hintergründe zu Russlands Krieg gegen
die Ukraine dem Treffen der
Außenminister und was Moskau dazu sagt
finden Sie bei uns natürlich wie immer
auch online auf ZDF heute
und jetzt geht es bei Dir weiter Heinz
mit dem Blick auf den Tag der Deutschen
Einheit in Hamburg haben die
Feierlichkeiten dazu schon heute
begonnen mit einem großen Bürgerfest das
am Mittag von Hamburgs erstem
Bürgermeister
chenscher offizielle eröffnet wurde
unter dem Motto Horizonte öffnen werden
zu dem zweitägigen fest hunderttausende
Besucher erwartet Höhepunkt der
Feierlichkeiten ist morgen der Festakt
in der Elbphilharmonie
in einer ZDF-Dokumentation zum Tag der
Deutschen Einheit hat sich auch die
frühere Bundeskanzlerin Merkel geäußert
es war ihr erstes TV-Interview nach
ihrer Kanzlerschaft sie spricht darin
unter anderem darüber warum sie sich
erst zum Ende ihrer Amtszeit zu Ihrer
persönlichen DDR-Geschichte äußerte
weil ich mich immer als Kanzlerin aller
deutschen verstanden habe vielleicht
auch manchmal nicht so getraut habe aus
der DDR-Zeit
frank und frei dauern zu sprechen weil
das wieder auch so eine Art
Stigmatisierung geworden wäre jetzt
kommt sie wieder mit ihrem
Ostdeutschland
das Interview mit der Kanzlerin für die
Dokumentation am Puls wie viel Einheit
haben wir erreicht wird morgen nach der
19 Uhr heute Sendung ausgestrahlt und
gibt es schon jetzt in voller Länge in
unsere ZDF heute App
aus Protest gegen die Gesundheitspolitik
der Bundesregierung sind heute
bundesweit viele Fach- und
Hausarztpraxen geschlossen geblieben bei
einer zentralen Demonstration in Berlin
legt niedergelassene Medizinerinnen und
Mediziner symbolisch ihre Kittel vor die
Tür des Bundesgesundheitsministeriums
ihre Forderung die Zitat schmerzhaften
Sparmaßnahmen so Lasten der Praxen und
ihre Patienten müssten zurückgenommen
werden bei Krankenkassen und
patientenschützern stießen die Aktionen
auf Kritik
in New York hat heute ein Zivilverfahren
gegen den früheren US-Präsidenten Trump
wegen Vorwürfen des finanzbetrugs
begonnen die Staatsanwaltschaft
beschuldigt ihn seine beiden ältesten
Söhne und leitende Mitarbeiter unter
anderem jahrelang die Vermögenswerte der
Familien Holding manipuliert zu haben um
günstigere Kredite zu bekommen im Falle
einer Verurteilung drohen Trump ein
Bußgeld in Millionenhöhe und ein Verbot
in New York Geschäfte zu machen Trump
weist alle Vorwürfe zurück
Riesenspektakel heute im Hamburger Hafen
die feierliche Taufe des größten
deutschen containerschiffes auf der
berlin-express werden künftig mehr als
23.600 Container Platz finden voll
beladen wird sie den Hamburger Hafen
aber gar nicht anlaufen können das alte
Problem Hamburg liegt nun mal nicht
direkt am Meer und die Elbe ist als
Wasserstraße nicht tief genug auch wenn
sie im Laufe der Zeit immer wieder
vertieft wurde bereits zum 1900 wurde
die Elbe tiefer gegraben auf etwa sechs
Meter seitdem ist sie noch mehrfach
ausgebaggert worden zuletzt vor zwei
Jahren inzwischen können Frachter mit
einem Tiefgang von bis zu 14,5 Metern
einlaufen bei der direkten Konkurrenz im
Nordseehafen von Rotterdam sind dagegen
20 Meter Wassertiefe längst Standard das
ist natürlich ein massiver
Wettbewerbsnachteil für Hamburg
dazu kommt noch dass die Farbe in der
regelmäßig mit Schlick und Sand verläuft
baggerschiffe kommen mit dem Entfernen
gar nicht hinterher deshalb musste die
schiffbare Wassertiefe wieder reduziert
werden seitdem ist noch weniger Ladung
erlaubt aber das sind nicht die einzigen
sorgen die die Feierlichkeiten heute
etwas überschattet
berichtet aus Hamburg
ausgerechnet Berlin Express taufte Elke
Büdenbender die Frau des
Bundespräsidenten das neue Flaggschiff
der hapag-traderei auf den Namen der
Hauptstadt die Hamburg schon so viel
versprochen hat Hilfe beim Elbe
Ausbaggern der Schienenanbindung
Landstrom und Digitalisierung doch seit
Jahren bleibt es bei Versprechungen wir
haben vor allem die First Lady Frau
wütenbänder heute gewinnen können dieses
Flaggschiff der deutschen Handelsflotte
zu taufen und das mag vielleicht auch
ein Signal sein dass man in Berlin ein
Auge wirft auf für den größten deutschen
Seehafen und die Notwendigkeit die
maritimische Schifffahrt in Deutschland
zu halten sie auch voranzubringen weil
Hamburg das aber nicht schnell genug
geht hat sich die Stadt jetzt selbst
einen finanzstarken privaten Partner
gesucht die Schweizer Reederei MSC
übernimmt zu der Plan
49,9% der Betriebsgesellschaft des
Hamburger Hafens erstmals also kauft
eine Reederei nicht nur ein Kapazitäten
an einem Terminal sondern Anteile des
gesamten Hafens also der Holding
Investitionssumme noch geheim klar wir
sind auch beteiligen an der Häfen das
brauchen wir auch wir wachsen wir
wachsen Schonung wir haben mehr als
hunderte Neubau Schiffe unterwegs
deswegen brauchen wir die Kapazität
Antwerpen und rotterdamen sind Hamburgs
Hauptkonkurrenten dort unterstützen die
Niederlande und Belgien ihre Häfen und
dort wächst der Hafenumschlag um 20%
jährlich in Hamburg dagegen ging der
Umschlag zuletzt um 6 % zurück insgesamt
wünschen wir uns natürlich die richtige
Investition in den Hafeninfrastruktur
das ist nicht nur hier in Hamburg ja
aber auch in Bremen Bremerhaven und
Wilhelmshaven man muss einfach mit
investieren um weiterhin mitzuhalten
auch mit den roten Damen und Antworten
Recht vor und wartet nicht dass der Bund
investiert MSC soll es richten und
verspricht Investitionen und sehr viel
mehr Ladung in Hamburg die aber gibt der
Weltmarkt eigentlich nicht her Hamburger
Deal wird daher die anderen deutschen
Häfen einiges an Umsatzkosten natürlich
wird am Ende wahrscheinlich Bremerhaven
der große Verlierer aus diesem Deal sein
weil die ladungspakete die im Moment in
Bremerhaven sind dann wahrscheinlich
eher nach Hamburg rüber wandern insofern
rückt Bremerhaven so ein bisschen so
eine sandwich-position dann zwischen
Hamburg und Antwerpen vor allem auch
Hapag Lloyd hatte übrigens darauf
gehofft im großen Stil in Hamburg
einsteigen zu können die neue
containerschiffklasse heißt wohlwollend
Hamburg Express klasse und auch wenn
heute die Berlin Express dran war das 7
Schiff der Serie wird Hamburg Express
heißen es ist wie mit der nationalen
hafenstrategie die haben sie Arten
brauchen Geduld
tja eine echte gemeinsame nationale
hafenstrategie gibt es bisher jedenfalls
nicht da ist sich ganz föderal doch
jeder selbst am nächsten mit den
Gemeinsamkeiten tun wir uns ja eh nicht
ganz leicht das wird sicher auch morgen
wieder ein Thema sein beim Tag der
Deutschen Einheit dabei ziehen sich die
Konfliktlinien bei politischen
Einstellungen und Weltbildern keineswegs
nur entlang einer Ost-West-Achse diesen
Gräben und graben kämpfen widmet sich
die ZDF-Dokumentation die streitrepublik
die zweite Folge dieser Doku wird morgen
Mittag um 12 Uhr ausgestrahlt sie ist
aber schon jetzt in der Mediathek
abrufbar deine Vorausschau darauf
liefern uns die Autoren Melanie Haag und
Peter kurz
vier deutsche zwei Sofas Streit und
politische Fronten
die war total pleite was ist denn der
Staat jetzt mit Billionen Schulden aber
es funktioniert ja alles noch noch
Heiko braun und Tochter Rebecca aus
Thüringen er ist
afd-protestfeder sie fühlt sich von der
Politik nicht abgeholt vierertreffen zum
dritten Oktober Christian von Gierke war
mal im Bundesvorstand der Grünen ihr
Sohn ist
afd-fraktionspressesprecher im
nordrhein-westfälischen Landtag
ich hasse dieses Jahr Westen Osten ja
also früher haben gesagt bzw sagen ja
die meisten immer noch aber das finde
ich auch übertrieben inzwischen ich habe
selber benutzt wie war das denn damals
nach der Wiedervereinigung ich würde
mich da nicht als Fan der wie man damals
sagt aber Ossis bezeichnen sondern war
da eigentlich eher sehr ablehnend und
auch von oben herab arrogant wir haben
gewonnen aber es ist blöderweise hängen
geblieben dieser arrogante Blick auf die
Ostdeutschen Heiko braun im Film
streitrepublik beschrieb der
Maschinenbauer seinen Weg ins gemeinsame
Deutschland nach 33 Jahren ist es für
ihn keine Verheißung mehr wir haben uns
aufgedrückt Kapitalismus Westen alles
gut alles Friede Freude Eierkuchen die
im Osten groß geworden sind das ist
jetzt die Generation die jetzt Richtung
Rente geht die vergleicht immer stärker
das System
und sie haben in den 30 Jahren gefühlt
für mich auch gemerkt auch dieses System
hat Ecken und Kanten ohne Ende deswegen
ist momentan Kultur im Osten auf
mittiger
Protestwähler Unmut den die AFD für sich
einsammeln will wer ist denn wirklich
Opposition und wer ist für das ganze
nicht verantwortlich weil er nie in
Regierungsverantwortung war das sind nur
wir eine Partei die die Reihen nach
außen schließt mit dem rechtsextremen
thüringischen Landesvorsitzenden Björn
höcke mittendrin
er benutzt wirklich Nazi Begriffe
faschistische Begriffe völkische
Begriffe die die
das kannst du dann machen Mutter
Christiane und Sohn Chris
und die familientoleranz kommt an ihre
Grenzen
hören und ich weigere mich auch immer
dagegen immer zu distanzierlich von
diesem distanziere dich von diesem muss
ich nicht
solange afd-mitglied ist es ja auf die
Mitglied Punkt ich habe dir gesagt wenn
du jemals die Meinung von höcke
vertrittst dann bist du für mich
wirklich auch rechtsradikal dann kann
ich eigentlich unsere Diskussions Ebene
nicht mehr akzeptieren rote Linie auch
in einer streitrepublik
und jetzt noch mal Reiz mit dem Blick
auf die Finanzmärkte die Finanzaufsicht
Bafin hat einen Sonderbeauftragten für
die Deutsche Bank bestellt das gab die
BaFin heute bekannt und teilte mit er
soll überwachen dass das Institut die
Einschränkungen im Kundenservice bei den
Niederlassungen Postbank und dsl-bank
zügig und vollständig beseitigt
materiala worum geht es da konkret also
die beiden IT-Systeme der Postbank und
der Deutschen Bank wurden mit großem
Aufwand zusammengeführt mit dem Ziel
jedes Jahr viel Geld zu sparen das hat
aber zu massiven Problemen geführt seit
Monaten häufen sich die Beschwerden der
Kunden zeitweise konnten sie nicht auf
ihre Konten zugreifen der Kundenservice
war kaum erreichbar Baukredite wurden
blockiert bafin-chef Branson bezeichnet
das Chaos bei der Postbank als
inakzeptabel Deutsche Bank Aktionäre
reagieren verschnupft mit über 3% im
Minus gehören die Papiere heute zu den
größten Verlierern im DAX selten oder
eine Bank so scharf von der Aufsicht
gerügt wie die Deutsche Bank ein
Aufpasser für den Verbraucherschutz das
hat das bislang noch nicht gegeben in
einem großen deutschen Finanzinstitut
und was bedeutet das für die Deutsche
Bank also für die Deutsche Bank ist das
eine teure Angelegenheit die Probleme zu
bewältigen kostet erst mal viel Geld
weil Leute dafür engagiert externe
firmenbeauftragt werden müssen ganz
abgesehen vom Imageschaden die Deutsche
Bank sagt sie wolle mit dem
Sonderbeauftragten eng zusammenarbeiten
und weitere Servicekräfte engagieren bis
Ende des Jahres will sie den Rückstau
aufgelöst haben manche sagen das sei
sehr ehrgeizig schafft sie das
jedenfalls nicht drohen weitere
Sanktionen materielle vielen Dank
die Arbeitslosigkeit in der Eurozone ist
trotz konjunkturellen gegen winds auf
einem historisch niedrigen Niveau von
6,4%
widerstatistikamt Euro statt bekannt
gegeben hat niedriger war die Quote seit
Einführung des Euro noch nie allerdings
verzeichnen die Statistiker bei der
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit aktuell eine
Quote von 13,8 %. Deutschland gehört
nach den Angaben zu den Ländern mit
niedriger gesamtarbeitslosenquote am
höchsten ist sie demnach in Spanien
nach dem Brand in mehreren Diskotheken
im spanischen Murcia sind fünf zunächst
noch vermisste Personen lebend gefunden
worden die Stadtverwaltung gab der mal
bekannt dass zwei der drei betroffenen
Clubs seit letztem Jahr keine
Betriebsgenehmigung mehr besaßen mit
einer Schweigeminute gedachten Politiker
und Behördenvertreter der insgesamt 13
Todesopfer am frühen Sonntagmorgen war
das Feuer in einem der Clubs
ausgebrochen die Ursache ist weiterhin
unklar
Tennisprofi alex hat beim ATP-Turnier in
Peking das Halbfinale erreicht der 26
Jahre alte Hamburger gewann gegen den
Chilene Nicolas Jerry in drei Sätzen und
spielt nun gegen den US Open Finalisten
Daniel mit WDR um den Einzug ins
Endspiel das wäre es auf seiner
china-tour der siebte Sieg in Serie in
der vergangenen Woche hatte er bereits
das Turnier in Chengdu gewonnen
als in der corona-pandemie die
sogenannten
mrna-impfstoffe angeboten wurden Chinas
unheimlich schnell gegangen zu sein was
ja bei manchen auch Verunsicherung
auslöste wo kommen die plötzlich her
doch so schnell oder plötzlich war das
gar nicht der
mrna-technologie ging Jahrzehnte der
Forschung voraus vor allem zwei Forscher
hatten sich der Entwicklung dieser
Medizintechnologie verschrieben eine
gebürtige Ungarin die damit schon in den
1980er Jahren begann und ein
US-Amerikaner schließlich gemeinsam
forschten an Corona dachten sie da noch
nicht es ging um eine grundsätzliche
Methode Körperzellen mit Informationen
zu versorgen und Krankheiten zu
bekämpfen dafür bekommen die beiden den
diesjährigen Medizin Nobelpreis
Christina kayatz erzählt ihre Geschichte
ihre Zusammenarbeit begann Ende der 90er
Jahre als man sich noch am Kopierer
treffen konnte und niemand ahnte welches
Potenzial sich hinter ihren Ideen
verbirgt die in Ungarn geborene Katalin
kariko und der US-Amerikaner drobeisenen
forschen gemeinsam an der Universität
von Pennsylvania viele Jahre
entschlossen nicht locker zu lassen
obwohl sich die Wissenschaft kaum für
sie interessiert
[Musik]
wir konnten keine Forschungsgelder
bekommen wir konnten nicht publizieren
und niemandem klar machen wie
interessant RNA ist klinische Studien
scheiterten und fast jeder auf diesem
Gebiet gab auf
ich war für die RNA zuständig er der
Immunologe und wir haben uns gegenseitig
etwas beigebracht wir haben gemeinsam
gelernt und dann 2005 publiziert wie man
messenger-rna herstellen kann die keine
Entzündungen auslöst
Entzündungen waren bis dahin ein Problem
allerdings sorgt auch die
Veröffentlichung 2005 in der Fachwelt
nicht für Euphorie
2013 kommt Katalin kariko nach
Deutschland arbeitet für den Mainzer
Konzern biontech auf der Grundlage ihrer
Forschung gelingt Jahre später während
der corona-pandemie die Entwicklung
einer ganz neuen Art von Impfstoffen in
atemberaubender Geschwindigkeit
die Konzerne biontech und moderner
bringen als erste sogenannte
mrna-impfstoffe auf den Markt ein
entscheidender Schritt um die Pandemie
zu besiegen
für einen mrna-impfstoff wird ein Teil
der Erbinformationen des Virus kopiert
der Vorteil dieser Impfstoffe sie
enthalten keine Anteile des Virus
sondern nur genetische Informationen die
mRNA überlebt nur kurz kann das Erbgut
des geimpften nicht verändern sie
liefert aber den Bauplan für die
spike-proteine die dann an der Zellhülle
platziert werden das löst eine Reaktion
des Immunsystems aus
das Nobelkomitee würdigt diesen Erfolg
heute mit der höchsten Auszeichnung die
in der Wissenschaft zu vergeben ist und
sieht noch mehr Potenzial
das gesamte Feld der krebsimpfungen die
wir jetzt noch nicht haben aber es wird
sehr viele verschiedene krebsimpfungen
geben die sich gegen unterschiedliche
Tumore richten möglicherweise sogar
individuell abgestimmte Impfungen gegen
den Krebs
eine große Hoffnung aber die Erfolge
werden sich vielleicht nicht gleich
einstellen und die Wissenschaft einen
langen Atem brauchen so wie die
Nobelpreisträger dieses Tages
das was an uns gleich nach dem Wetter
geht es mit dem ZDF montagskino weiter
und um 0 Uhr gibt es dann unser heute
schon ein Update mit Nazan göktemir
[Musik]